welcome to this video playing us beyond
from um Norway right yes really should
know that by now still retained it
sometimes okay the NIMS oh let's see
what line the check the damage my own
line let's see efore 98 that's what I'm
expecting but there are other lines I
mean one one interesting aspect is that
there are so many tricky sidelines and
already know g3 for example it's
interesting now here is also going from
Nigeria let's see can i donate a five I
think I so can the only real important
thing is to always have 98 after you
form I have to actually play it it's
still there are many many dangerous some
possibilities here for example it's
difficult for white are ready to keep
the sea for porn but you might get some
dangerous compensation yeah should I
take now on night 96 gal 96 e 59 txt for
you then I have all pieces of side
what about you 5 u 5f 4 u 5f for now
this depends on f4f six if i can play
that it might be okay f6e can't a crook
at vineland queen h5 just double
attacking okay i didn't do that that's
an interesting move as well or e five
was was probably very very questionable
if I cannot go to the six with my night
oh ok let's let's exchange stuff the
night on a fiver some and maybe I could
have played night be 726 yeah well
whatever is what I'm trying to do is to
exchange the somewhat offside night for
the bishop here so that f4 will not be
so powerful at least I hope or the dark
squares are not such a big problem now
he can try to
somehow can you blame bishop age six
could be a move to play ok I can take it
Queen g4 check there's no made on just
have nabbed ok
yeah still hmm seems strange to spend so
much time him White has a good position
anyway with the muffler group b 1 okay
he's sacrificing okay I need to take it
anyway okay so g6 Roxy seven bishops e8
and hope that my position survives this
attack it's possible it's not like I'm
completely defenseless the night on the
edge has some defensive qualities i know
i'm i can maybe take and play 96 yeah
come on this should be okay this should
be okay that's this night must go okay
and our if 6cm I must do that I cannot
allow him to play at six and our 96 and
probably form
okay yeah that's helpful yeah this
whatever it was really unreason
necessary to 22 sec this exchange you
can just play a move like like rugby one
and then be in good shape thought this
was interesting here i need so i need to
do something i need to play some
improvement other computer has a good
suggestion queen age who I am this is a
dozen move I like you know that Queen
edge fries one of my one of my pet moves
I like to a late like to do that yeah it
keeps all options open and it looks at
sensitive squares Queen h5 this kind of
stuff is prevented yeah may e 5 is not
good this is not good if I cannot go to
g6 I mean I know I don't know how bad it
is but if I persistent it's a nun to
enter positional move it really is I
thought I forgot that really that died
f5 is coming immediately and I thought
okay next move 96 and I'm fine yeah now
this is it simply not necessary you can
you can do a simple move like that and
now I now continue with g 3 a 4 for
example it's just just the normal
position that you can play but you're
not you're not an exchange down when the
exchange is not may be totally decisive
but it's not necessary to sacrifice him
ok thanks for watching